so thanks to the new intro for season 4
we finally have subtle confirmation on
the new characters and arcs that will
round out the second half of the season
not to mention a brief look at dad bod
oh my yeah he did not deserve this I'm
gonna give a quick breakdown on the new
confirmed characters that we've not seen
before in the anime and give a non
spoiler overview of something that was
easy to miss from the outro but before
we begin thank you guys so much for
getting the channel to 30k I said that
we might be able to do it by the end of
January and we've done it with a week to
spare so I really appreciate it guys
okay so before the season began it was
widely assumed that it would end with
the cultural festival arc from the manga
and this was largely because the overall
arc was the longest in my hair academia
history and we expected it to take up
the majority of the season I remember
some people on Twitter even saying that
it might take up the entire season which
just that was just crazy but what we've
confirmed today is that the series will
actually end with the pro hero arc which
serves as the introduction to the
greatest of all time Hawks okay that was
probably an exaggeration I feel like
Hawks is so popular that even if you've
never even read the manga or even
touched it you'll still know who he is
but for those of you who don't Hawks is
the fastest character in my hair
academia and as a professional hero
ranked directly behind endeavor and all
might as you would expect I explained
this character in more detail in my
hawks explained video which you can
check out after this one but to cut a
long story short he has a really
interesting backstory and was
essentially sponsored from a young age
to become a hero by the government and
as a result of this training he was the
youngest person ever to break into the
top ten heroes and has the expertise
that many other heroes don't have for
example his negotiation tactics as well
as mastering the art of infiltration and
sending coded messages this was very
subtly referenced in the outro where we
see this image of a young Hawks being
blindfolded and chaperoned by some guy
in a suit presumably training his senses
and also his quirk Hawks is one of the
more interesting characters in this
series because while he is morally
questionable sometimes I'm sure most
people who've read the manga would agree
that at the core of his actions he has
good intentions so he's not a
black-and-white character by any means
and his quirk is also one of the most
deadly in this series as he can control
each individual feather with telekinesis
and some of them are actually strong
enough
be used as feather swords but like I
said I explained the many other aspects
of his quirk in my other video which
I'll link to in the description now
hoaxes appearance this season was
essentially confirmed by two shots from
the new opening one of which is just too
spoilery to post in this video but it
essentially confirmed an iconic shot
from the pro hero arc and the other shot
is this one here which what I'm sure it
probably was from the manga I had a
quick skim through it this morning and I
couldn't find it but regardless of that
hoax will be appearing this season and I
love the way that this has been handled
as he was foreshadowed earlier on in the
season when Takayama he was offered the
internship and that was a scene created
specifically for the anime so kudos to
the studio for thinking ahead it means
that when Hawkes does show up it won't
really be out of the blue as many people
would have already known of him from
that scene earlier on in the season
Hawkes does already have a Japanese
voice actor as the hero's rising movie
which came out in December last year
featured Hawks prominently or at least
to an extent I haven't actually seen it
yet myself but as far as the English dub
there's been no official confirmation on
who will play Hawks
but it's got to come within like the
next month or so not just because of the
anime but also because Hiro's rising is
coming out on the 26th of February I
believe
and while Hawkes was the main character
that I was excited to see confirmed we
also got a few other crumbs of
information for example we got to see
Mirko who's another character making her
debut in the pro-hero arc and she's
actually ranked in the top 5 heroes her
quirk is called rabbit which essentially
lets her do anything a rabbit can do
which is not too dissimilar from fra P
and it also means that she never really
has to do leg day as her tree trunk legs
are pretty solid regardless and as I
mentioned earlier we had something for
shattered in the outro that you could
have easily missed we see a flashback of
young Aizawa and present Mike at UA and
alongside them is their childhood best
friend Sharaku mo the foreshadowing here
is gonna be crazy in like two or three
seasons as this ties into both the
vigilantes manga and just some crazy
things that are gonna happen in the main
series but with that said before we can
even meet Hawks and get into the pro
hero arc we do have to get through the
cultural festival which began in the
episode today and I'll admit it's not my
favorite arc in Maya academia I don't
even think it's close but I can't deny
that gentle criminal who is the main
villain is an incredibly well-written
character with a pretty awesome quirk as
well and I think I'll likely do a video
explaining him
sometime soon one last thing before I go
this wasn't actually the video I was
planning to release this weekend as you
can imagine as the info only came out
this morning so because of that I'm
gonna have a new video coming out
tomorrow that I've already made so keep
an eye out for that as I'll be
explaining the first volume of my hair
academia vigilantes which for those of
you that don't know it's a prequel to my
hero academia and it shows off a bunch
of characters that you already know
including Aizawa fat gum all my and
Ingenium and it introduces some new
characters as well so yeah be sure to
keep an eye out for that and I'll see
you guys tomorrow
peace